it's not it's not anything about who you
are as a person but it's what men value
so you can't so so you can't go up to
guys and say don't value this because
it's what they want so that's like me
selling a car and going up to the people
that want to buy a car and say like this
car and they say no I don't want to buy
that car because it's got too many miles
and you're saying well you should light
cars with high miles
honestly we're talking about completely
different things so women can't get no
title like that because when she's
saying that nobody's gonna know you have
about 30 Men You're gonna be as Loose as
held men no and like the thing is you
know and at the end of the day if a
woman sleeps with loads of men she's a
she's a
loads of women is a stud yeah so that
gives the show from the beginning and
that's I'm sorry but you we didn't make
that rule as well no but that's the way
it is yeah if that's the way it is